[Music]
[Applause]
Greg McElroy former Alabama quarterback
the ESPN ABC college football analyst
he'll be calling Florida at Kentucky
this Saturday at 7 Eastern and is the
host of the always college football
podcast uh ESPN podcast and co-host
on Mornings in
wjox in Birmingham Alabama and he was on
the call for Florida State LSU on Sunday
night Greg good to have you back who did
more to lose the game LSU or Florida
State
well they say more games are lost than
one right Dan and I mean I'm not sure
there was a better example of that in
week one than what we saw there in New
Orleans uh a cacophony of errors but I I
would honestly say the game should have
been comfortably in favor of Florida
State whether you look at the fourth and
two or they went for it early as opposed
to taking the points after they dropped
the first punt the fumble at the end
zone at the very end as they're putting
the game on Ice that those two plays
right there I mean those are 14 points I
mean the game should have been sideways
in favor of FSU so uh I would say that
that LSU made more mistakes and fsu's
inability to really take advantage of
those were kind of troubling something
to be completely honest you played the
position of quarterback that call comes
in where it's a pitch down by the goal
line which I I don't understand the
logic that you would have anything other
than take a knee kick a field goal or
just hand it to him and let your running
back take help me understand what that
play was or what it should have been
well I'm 100 with you and we had a rule
at all levels of football the ball never
went in the air backwards along the goal
line it just there's absolutely no
reason for it now they ran that play
earlier in the game you get into a
muddle huddle it's try to create gaps
they have unbalance set to the right and
just pitch it out but there's just too
many things that could potentially go
wrong as the field condenses so I I
think it makes absolutely no sense like
some coaches are willing to put the ball
in the air but I as a conservative
player and understanding the
circumstances of the game a field goal
ends it I mean you're a buck 25
remaining I actually thought that there
was a real reason for LSU to let them
score because I think that the odds if
you play the odds and statistically
speaking from an analytical standpoint I
have a better chance of coming down
coming back from two touchdowns than I
do stopping them at the one yard line uh
from kicking a field goal uh so I mean
the like the odds actually would say hey
let him score then get our offense on
the field go down two minute kicking
outside kick go down do it again but
either way I mean it just made
absolutely no sense so the the risk far
outweighed the reward and if they would
have just handed it off and kicked a
field goal it's game set match
give me the team give me the school that
played its way out of the final four
already
it's hard to say play your way out
um but Utah would be the team that would
that would come to mind and it's not
because they can't potentially win 12 in
a row and get back into the playoff mix
I think that's possible it's but what I
was most disappointed in Dan and and I I
don't know if you felt the same way but
when you talk all off season about a
team strength being their front seven
defensively and that front seven
defensively looked average that's a
little concerning if you look at Florida
for instance I know it's new coach new
regime all this other stuff it's fine
but Florida's offensive line the last
five or six years has been less than
Stellar they've gotten by with smoking
mirrors and Dan mullen's run scheme
would occasionally get good run yardage
but this has not been a mauling group to
see Florida's offensive line for the
first time in five years mauling people
off the line of scrimmage was
eye-opening especially knowing that
that's supposed to be Utah's greatest
strength so I think they can still get
back in the mix but the likelihood of
them going 12 row I think is almost an
impossibility at this point Notre Dame
can you have a good loss this early in
the season and still be in the hunt
very much so I mean we've seen Ohio
State for instance 2014 lose week two
they looked off for week one against
Navy one uh week two they lost to
Virginia Tech by two touchdowns they
rallied to win 13 a row but that's the
type of personnel Ohio state has I think
what I was most troubled by is Notre
Dame really lacked a ton of
explosiveness as far as their offensive
weapons are concerned
um not that they've ever really not that
we expected them to be super Elite at
wide receiver but I was kind of
disappointed I mean this is an Ohio
State team that really hasn't been great
on defense the last couple years I know
that they're starting over with a new
defensive coordinator and Jim Knowles
but I've just thought that there would
be more Firepower from Notre Dame so
yeah they can get back in the mix but I
just don't think you can win like
Wisconsin wins every week and you know
expect to get to the college football
playoff but you can't just grind out W's
over and over and over again I mean you
can but there's going to be a team who
catches fire offensively and if you
can't keep up in a shootout it's going
to be a problem so I was impressed by
what they did defensively but
offensively I'm not sure they have they
have the horsepower to get it done
speaking of which Oregon against Georgia
that I mean that's that would be a
no-show basically like you're there in
in body but I don't know if you're there
in mind in Seoul what happened was that
like what was your impressions of I mean
Georgia looked like a finely tuned
machine that was for a week one game
against a decent opponent that was
Clinic real I mean it was it was
unbelievable if you ever seen a team
come out guns are blazing like that
against a solid competition well it made
me wonder just how good Oregon is
um because I I have my doubts about
Georgia just replacing everybody but
still they're still replacing people
with people that everybody else in the
country wanted uh Stetson Bennett you
know he's just one of those guys that
you go all right he just kind of gets it
done kind of like you in college he just
yes it does it's kind of a stetson's
just kind of a baller I mean you know
it's like one of those guys it it feels
like he's gonna get done with the game
and you know go go to the frat house and
you know drink a case of beer like he's
just such a guy like you know he's but
you just he's a baller man like he is he
just makes plays and I think his is he's
very creative he can make the off
schedule play but he played in Rhythm
the other night and and their weapons
are ridiculous I mean they're off I mean
they got tight ends there's third best
tight end might be you know one of the
best tied in America and that's Derek
Gilbert there are other two tight ends
Brock Bowers is he's literally Travis
Kelsey and the same guy I mean they're
just unbelievable athleticism and then
they have a tackle basically they tackle
bodies six eight two eighty uh in
Darnell Washington who can run and plays
tight end uh so I mean they're they're
wet and then their weapons on the
outside are ridiculous their running
backs aren't might be better this year
and that's saying a lot because I
thought James Cook who I is with Buffalo
now I think he's going to have a
phenomenal rookie year so I I just think
I'm I mean it's it's unbelievable to
watch what they did the other day uh and
nobody wants to wants to play Georgia if
they're playing like that talking to
Greg McElroy ESPN ABC college football
analyst he'll be on the call with
Kentucky and Florida this Saturday when
you guys would get ready at Alabama for
a cupcake
North Texas
Florida International Chattanooga
what was Nick Saban's pregame speech
with those games as opposed to facing
Auburn he was much harder on you those
weeks you know playing Auburn it's like
all right guys hey let's go out there
and play hard you know but against
Tennessee chat it's like if you guys
don't do this this this you're losing
this week like you know it like then
it's the craziest thing and you know I
think coaching like every any coach you
know their little kind of minor in
Psychology right I can vividly remember
Tean it up against Tennessee Chattanooga
we were 10-0 in 2009 played in the
second to last week of the Season
45 to nothing I can vividly remember
taking the field being like we better
play well today or we're going to lose
like I mean oh so you bought into
savings it convinces you of that it's
like and I I now my senior year I was I
wasn't quite as naive uh you know we're
playing against you know Georgia State
or whoever it was it's like all right
we're gonna smoke these guys like let's
just get out of this thing healthy
um but playing against Tennessee chat in
my junior year I mean he can just he
knows how to press your buttons to the
point in which you're never comfortable
you're always uneasy and when you're
uneasy against a team like that the
urgency kind of elevates a little bit
and you know he's always going to say
we're going to play to our standard and
all this other stuff so uh the messaging
is is clear if you don't play well you
will be replaced regardless of who the
opponent is
what do you see with with USC uh the the
timetable of them coming back into
prominence
uh I think we are so far out in front of
our skis uh right now with SC and people
saying they're a playoff team people
saying they're they're all these other
things they might very well be
um but it's gonna be by a process of
elimination in the Pac-12 like if they
make it to the college football playoff
it's going to be because they beat a
bunch of teams that probably probably
aren't Elite in an effort to get there
um but SC if you have a quarterback you
have a chance right always and they have
an elite quarterback I mean Caleb
Williams is phenomenal uh has a couple
years of Eligibility left but he'll be a
top five pick no doubt about it Game
Changer uh but what I was most impressed
with the other day was their ball
Hawking mentality on defense and look
Oklahoma had their fair share of ups and
downs and Lincoln Riley's tenure on the
defensive side but I actually think they
got it right with the higher it's just
gonna take a couple of years at Oklahoma
to kind of change the culture but the
defensive culture at SC has been
lethargic for a really long time that
was probably one of the more inspired
defensive performances I've seen I know
it's rice like let's not get carried
away but you have three pick sixes I
mean there's something to be said there
that was the first time they've had
multiple pick sixes in the game I think
in like 20 years and they had I believe
one defensive touchdown last year they
had three in the first game of the
Lincoln Riley era so I think they're
ahead of schedule but for us to now
starting to starting to lump them in
with the best teams in college football
I they got a long way to go before they
get there
we always Crown a September Heisman
and it might be Anthony Richards in the
Florida quarterback it feels like the
guy who is unbelievable in September and
maybe not so much in December
although I'm hearing great things about
Richardson that he could be a top 10
draft pick I mean is that far-fetched
that he was behind Kyle Trask and that
guy could be you know a higher draft
pick than Trask
no because I mean we've seen that before
I mean like Mitch trubisky was you know
make what make of it what you what you
will I mean he was a backup until his
senior year he had a guy that was mobile
because he was a better fit for the
offense so I think sometimes it's just
while Trask was a good player uh it was
an accurate thrower I think the more
unjustifiable
guy that was in front of him on the
depth chart was Emory Jones uh he was
the starter throughout all of last year
and Anthony Richardson played at times
but probably should have been the guy
from the jump based on what we've seen
when I watched this guy see Vince Young
um the people have compared him to Cam
Newton people have compared him to Tebow
I I don't see it that way at all I think
uh Tebow was a power Runner he was
essentially a full-back you know playing
quarterback
um and then cam was a little bit more
physical as well where it's mostly going
to be about his raw power and he's going
to pick up your five and six yards now
he can get in the open field but cam was
more physically imposing when I watched
Anthony Richardson I see Vince Young
because of the fluidity and the
effortless nature with how he kind of
goes about his business I mean it's just
he's so fluid and he's moving he doesn't
even look like he's running but he's
faster than anyone on the field uh he
can just the way his body and his head
moves and his arm moves and just
everything if you watch them them side
by side the comparison is it's Unique
just how similar they are now I would
also compare him to a sophomore Vince
Young and I grew up in Dallas and went
to the Texas Oklahoma game every year so
I watched Vince Young Come of age over
the course of a four-year period and
Vince Young as a sophomore is about
where Anthony Richardson is the freak
Show athleticism is on display every
week but there's also a certain like
he's a little erratic at times in the
passing game he isn't great on the
downfield throws but it's in there so
it's coming it's just that's the path
that he's on right now so yes he will I
think in time be a super Elite
multi-dimensional player but right now
he's just such a god-given athlete it's
just incredible to watch Before I Let
You Go I mentioned this in the first
hour the program that we're going to 12
teams by 2026 unless they break the
contract and then they move this up a
little bit sooner but that's a lot of
time in college football because a lot
of things happen
quickly and I'm wondering if it's a
three-year window here
and I'm wondering if there's a
restructuring of college football over
three years to get us to this 12-team
playoff where maybe we have 50 or 60
teams that are the halves and then you
have the have-nots am I too far down the
road too quickly uh with with what what
I think is eventually going to happen in
college football
uh I think that actually the 12 team
playoff uh kind of slows that down a
little bit Dan to be honest with you um
I thought that that was where we were
heading uh and I wasn't sure if it was
going to be a you know a three-year
period a five-year period a 10-year
period with a grant of rights deal with
the ACC you know they're fairly stable
until 2036 or so
um but I think the 12 team playoff cools
further expansion for the moment and
partly because of the automatic
qualifiers right now the structure that
they're going to kind of promote is a
six a 12 team playoff with six automatic
qualifiers meaning the top six
Conference champions as far as the
rankings concerned will automatically
make the playoff it doesn't matter if
you're from the Mountain West or The
American or the Pac-12 the Big 12 the
SEC or the Big Ten the reward for
winning the SEC and the Big Ten is the
exact same as the reward for winning uh
a more getable Pac-12 so what would be
the reasoning for say an organ to leave
and join the Big Ten immediately I I
don't think that they're going to be in
a huge rush I also don't think that the
big tens is in a huge rush to further
expand but does it make more sense
though Greg that you know USC why not
stay in the Pac-12 where if you get an
automatic birth or Oklahoma why not stay
in the Big 12 instead of going in with
the big boys here and and maybe there's
so much more money to be made but I I
was wondering about that if you get an
automatic birth and you win the Big 12
who cares I mean right you get that
money and or if you win the Pac-12 in
your USC well you're right but I mean
when we're talking about
you know maybe double what they'll make
annually uh I'm not sure what the
pac-12's deal is going to look like that
deal is being currently negotiated I
think it'll be based on what I've heard
I've heard they might even structure it
in a way where every team kind of has
their own deal in an effort to you know
if there is future expansion there's not
a grant of rights you so basically let's
say ESPN for instance gets the deal that
they sign a deal with Oregon they sign a
deal with Pac-12 but Oregon's payouts
different from Cal and that would kind
of adjust accordingly so if Oregon went
to the Big Ten then ESPN could retain
Oregon's rights and this get a piece of
the Big Ten deal I don't you know I
don't know these are all these all rumor
in hearsay but you're right I mean you
wouldn't because if you're playing in
the Big Ten the likelihood of getting
into the playoff is still increasingly
High because of the strength of schedule
um so SC and UCLA will still be
benefited after having made the move
financially and because of the schedule
that they'll be able to play but you're
right I mean the Pac-12 will probably be
a one-bid league yeah the Big Ten might
have as many is for in the college
football playoff in an expanded field so
there's still a lot of value to being
aligned with the big boys
uh thanks for talking to us we always
appreciate it and uh have fun Florida
and Kentucky this Saturday night at 7
Eastern on the mothership thank you Greg
you're the best buddy appreciate it
that's Greg McElroy host of the always
college football podcast on ESPN